good morning believe nation today's
message is have a game plan over to you
Dana White TV go the biggest mistake
that everybody makes when they try to
compete with us as they try to compete
with us first of all we didn't come out
yesterday and put together an
organization and now we're on Fox and
now are on pay-per-view anything you do
nothing nothing is nothing happens
overnight manats it seems that way but
it's all hard work I have been on planes
trains and automobiles for the last 13
years outselling the sport getting deals
done getting door slammed on my face you
name it it's all happened and these guys
come out and they just start throwing
money around and start trying to be the
UFC don't try to be the UFC the first
thing you have to do when you start a
business is know exactly who you are and
what is your game plan you know what are
we going to do first first year is your
issues where you're looking what are we
going to do first year you make it
through that first year and you're still
alive all right what's our three year
plan you get into your three-year plan
and that's how you start to build your
company the last thing on this is how
stupid it is okay be like we're all
sitting around to my living room we're
all here we're hanging out my living
room and we're watching NASCAR okay holy
look at all the people at NASCAR these
guys must be making tons of money you
know what we should do we should go get
a couple of their drivers and let's
start our own race league and will
compete with NASCAR anybody want to jump
in with me hell no you know it sounds
like the stupidest idea ever but people
think they can do it with the UFC UFC
has been around for 20 years 20 years in
this November will be 13 years for us
and you think you're going to just dive
right in and start throwing money around
you will go out of business so fast so
what do you think yeah I think that's a
really great topic and you know I
remember in my life when I decided to go
pro with photography because it was
always a hobby for me now
pro I had a game plan that wasn't really
a game plan I just started shooting and
and I as I went on shooting at first I
look like everyone else might work
looked like everybody else's work and
then I started to experiment and start
to do stuff that made me really happy
and was really interesting and cool to
me so my pictures got cooler and more
different and weirder and more colorful
and more surreal than what was normal
and then I you know without even
noticing what I've done after about a
year I had my own unique style and
people were calling me specifically to
use me because I had like this unique
edgy look that other guys didn't so have
a game plan of what you want to do but
then explored kind of find what works
for you and and create your own what
makes you feel good will probably be
really great other people will connect
to it I love it and just to kind of riff
off of that I found a number of people
now write to me and they say hey evan is
this guy doing the same thing as you
he's doing another top 10 video or he's
using your content on his channel and do
you care and I get like multiple emails
a week from people like I don't care
right like I'm focused on what I'm doing
right and I think too many entrepreneurs
will often worry too much about the
competition and were too much what other
people are doing where you want to focus
on your game plan what you're great at
how you can be unique and not spend so
much time worrying about what everybody
else is doing and then the flip side of
that is as an entrepreneur when you're
trying to figure out what you're going
to do too many people all they do is
look to copy somebody else right like
even this Toronto dance asteroid we're
the biggest day in school in Canada for
sure probably North America we're bigger
than all of the other dance schools in
this area combined and people look at us
like oh I get started they in school too
i can copy what they're doing and you
know what I'm worried about are the
innovators right like somebody who just
looks at us and tries to copy it I don't
care at all because you can never out
tds tds you can never out Evan Evan
right you can out rich rich it's just
yeah not possible so I'm not worried
about the imitators when people come up
with new innovative ideas and so as a
start-up it's okay to model success
right I love Milan success look two
strategies that are working but then you
have to find a way to make them your own
you got to make them unique you're going
to add your own little secret sauce to
it so that people then do call you they
don't just see you as an imitator of
somebody
else the original the original have a
game our game plan to be Richard I like
it so the question the day today is what
gets you really excited what gets you up
motivated to do yeah I like it leave me
on comments below will join the
discussion thank you so much for
watching have an amazing day continue to
believe and we'll see you again tomorrow
morning for another shot of espresso